now we have to test this let's go back
to test provider once more it'll be
helpful to parameterize our tests a
little bit more both for location and
for date alright now that we've
parameterize our tests let's go back and
looking into our insert read provider
for the weather we're currently using
the raw content URI to query but we can
also query on additional data by cutting
and pasting this test we can try the
test with different query parameters
we'll close the cursor because it's good
practice now for our second weather
query wanna test the first of our new
you our eyes weather entry dot build
weather location and we can use our new
test location parameter all right let's
try running this test and our test
passed all right we're gonna add one
more test for the slight variation on
the query using build weather location
with start date instead so we're gonna
use test location as well as test date
and now let's run those tests and our
test pass now sometimes it's useful to
actually demonstrate a test failure
let's put in a date that's certainly
going to fail 201 506 24 we would expect
this test to fail let's try it and
indeed it fails so we're pretty sure
that our tests are actually doing what
we expect them to